uh chief correspondent stuart ramsey is
in doha and joins me now stuart you were
there at kabul airport
uh just hours ago um thousands of people
outside this could be potentially
devastating
it's exactly where it's happened as well
um
from our understanding from our people
who were there and we're talking to them
the
it was a suicide bomb attack in a canal
way
which um featured in in our reports for
the last few days where thousands and
thousands of people have been waiting to
have their applications heard we believe
that um
a suicide bomber blew himself up in the
canal
um this is overlooked by a number of um
american british and
multinational forces who are trying to
find people that we're being processed
to be processed
um we are not certain on the number of
casualties we have to assume
a number of civilians but uh initial
reports suggest to us that uh american
soldiers not british soldiers but
american soldiers have been injured
we've heard
of fatalities but we haven't been able
to confirm that at this stage
this was
uh predicted by
a number of sources
obviously including the governments for
a while and to us working there it was
so very clearly a a dangerous place to
be because
of the numbers of people coming through
the fact that there are no real checks
on what people are carrying or wearing
to get through
into this canal area
and that there was always a potential
for
an attack of some description
to just give it some context so
this is not inside the airport proper it
is on the perimeter wall of the airport
and it's one road that leads to the
processing area which is initially set
up by the british
um with british military which is a
protected area and there are lots of
paratroopers there they would also have
been on duty in that area as well but
slightly further down the road from
where we think the explosion took place
but so this is um a choke point if you
like where there are huge numbers of
people coming through from two
directions one that leads directly to
the british position and one that comes
more to what we've always described as
the american position and that is a
canal it's a sewage canal effectively
it's awful and people have been waiting
there for days and days to try and get
their cases heard
the explosion we believe took place in
that canal and that there will
definitely have been civilian casualties
because they would have been right next
to whoever uh blew themselves up
um we're still
sort of waiting for more details but you
know i can confirm the pentagon has but
we know that the the general location
it's probably a 50 to 100 meters long
stretch
that must at one stage have had
i mean thousands of people in it it has
been out over the last couple of days or
so so hopefully it's not as bad as it
could have been because it would have
been absolute carnage but um
the target would always have been not
the people per se but the the soldiers
and of course they have in amongst the
crowd trying to break pull them out
of the canal and look at their paperwork
um
as i said it had been predicted so what
does effect does this have on the
withdrawal and i think that's really the
important
point here is that this deadline that
was set was always going to be earlier
in terms of actually
people being processed
but um it
to me my expectation now
is that the forces will probably say
this is too dangerous and that might be
the end of this evacuation effort
because
given the
security issue
they they can't continue doing the job
they're doing in the way they're doing
it because it is so insecure by
definition so that
much
this event might be the end of the early